[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Mikey is
in San Diego what's going on Mikey um so
uh I recently got
married um and we've been expecting
Twins and so I'm trying to prepare for
the Twins and have like a five or seveny
year plan to to get a house I don't have
um we both combined don't have too much
in that that I um I think we should be
able to pay it off within at least I
feel like a year or
two
um it's a I think it's yeah it's around
40K in debt combined okay and what's
your household
income um so since she's working or
she's not working right now uh it's just
me it's 150 150,000 awesome great income
so why is it going to take two years to
clean up 40K making
150 um it's just because of the uh I
have a rent um that's at 30 it's like
3100 and then the utilities and um
whatever um I don't have a car payment
so it's pretty easy for me to like cover
all the regular bills on top of uh what
I have to try and pay down my um uh debt
but she I'm trying to get to her debt um
as fast as possible so I can help her oh
well I'm confused her debt my debt are
you guys married oh I'm sorry my bad our
debt I'm still getting used to it okay
newly cool I understand so the 40K debt
is both of y'all's debt
combined yes okay and what kind of debt
is
that uh it's mostly consumer and then
her I mean our uh student loan okay how
come she's not working
uh well she's pregnant right now so um
she had to pause what she was doing and
she um left her jobs and then she just
uh qualified for um disability so we
have that coming in now is she in poor
health no uh I mean she's pregnant with
the the twins now I'm sorry but was she
doing something that was physical that
she could no longer
do oh yes she was a massage therapist P
okay I I I mean I'm looking through the
glass right now at one of our people
behind the board who's pregnant and um
she's shown up kicking butt I know every
every Situation's different but I get
that man being a massage therapist
carrying twins I can't even I can't wrap
my head around that um but it might be
for a couple more months to find
something right and that's not me being
insensitive that's me just looking at y
have a math problem it's a pretty tough
situ situation to solve especially in
one of the most expensive real estate
markets in the United States and so
youall have some dreams and you have
some goals and there's some also
realities to those dreams and goals
right yes okay so making 50k you've got
40K do you have anything in
cash in the bank no not right now I mean
um so I have some side in Investments um
I didn't want to take out of 401k
obviously I have like my own person
investment account and then I have like
a bunch of um uh trading cards that I
used to invest into what's in the
personal investment account is that just
a non-retirement brokerage
account yeah uh it's like a Robin Hood
so uh there's only like seven 7,000 in
there oh only 7,000 that's a lot of
money that you use to throw the at the
debt right now okay we just got down to
33 what kind of cards you
got oh uh so I got Pokemon uh you know
Yu-Gi-Oh and then other um game called
like flesh and blood I had somebody
actually call into the show the other
day that paid off their debts by selling
um Pokemon cards not even playing you
can find it on YouTube that's a real how
much money you think all of your cards
are
worth truthfully well I know um just
give me a ballpark five grand it's about
like I'd say 70k
$7,000 yeah um I know the Market's a
little like rough right now but it's
about 70 I'm breaking the equipment here
I'm so excited Mikey listen dude do you
do you understand that your math
equation just changed you have 7,000 in
Robin Hood you have 70,000 in trading
cards and you have 40,000 in debt let's
go back to third grade math you're about
to be father of twins twin baby
girls if I'm you I'm like well my world
just changed I'm no longer in the
trading card business I'm in the dad
business and I want to set my wife up
these kids up for the best future
possible and that means when this baby's
born we have no debt and a giant
emergency fund you got those cards for
this moment right now and let me tell
you something both George and I are
parents of young kids the single most
important investment you can ever make
from this point forward is
time time just goes away and even um if
if I found a a 20-year-old he would not
trade places a broke 20-year-old would
not trade places with Warren Buffett who
has a hundred billion doll and he's 93
why because of
time and dude you can accelerate two
years of your life by selling trading
cards you cannot get those years back
especially years with
twins I would have those cards on the
market before Sunday strikes
midnight and i' probably sell them a
little bit undervalue just to get them
out of the house and start getting some
cash in and you will be debt free within
days you just bought yourself a year you
bought yourself two years is your life
back because you just told us that man
things are tight I'm not I'm it's going
to take me two years to get rid of this
debt or we Leap Frog this whole thing
you pay off all your debt this week you
still have 37,000 left if you do this
right that's your emergency fund right
now you're saving for for a house
starting November
15th dude yeah yeah are you going to do
any of this or are we just wasting air
right
now no I think I mean everybody's been
telling me that um what are you scared
of dude what are you scared of I feel
well it's because it feels like you know
a 401k for me at this point CU it's so
what does the trading cards I mean
having yeah you know what else used to
be stable Beanie Babies Google
that dude we don't know what if what if
Charizard gets cancelled and all of a
sudden your precious card is worth
nothing yes yeah they're going to start
cancelling Pokemon that's going to be
the new
thing okay dude you're sitting you're
sitting on two years of your life you
know what's a 401k Mikey a 401k and so
you're going to get there no time I
would quit playing games on Robin Hood
I'd quit the trading cards you're a
grown man with twin twin baby girls
let's start acting like it and you're
going to have 150 Grand coming in with
no debt with money in the bank saved get
your kids a house your wife can stay
home if she wants to with no stress it's
not even a conversation cuz you have
options at that point earli earlier
brother we did a debt-free screen with
this guy named Greg and he's one of my
new Heroes and he said I asked him
what's the key and he said men swallow
your pride and do what's right this is
that moment
dude this is that moment
we did our best John we'll see if it
works